voilà avec valérie vertal loriot co
secrétaire académique du snes fsu en
martinique
bonjour bonjour monsieur carrez alors
valérie vertal loriot en ce jour de
début des épreuves du baccalauréat
votre syndicat appelle à une grève de la
surveillance des examens alors ce n'est
pas une première mais c'est tout de même
assez rare pour être souligné et faire
l'objet donc de cette interview de ce
matin alors pourquoi perturber la bonne
tenue de ses épreuves du bac en quelque
sorte parce que c'est ça vous appelez à
cela s'agit pas de perturber il ne
s'agit pas non plus de
de mettre nos élèves en difficulté mais
il faut que les gens comprennent que les
temps sont extrêmement graves il ya tout
un ensemble de réformes qui mettent en
péril véritablement la scolarité de nos
lycéens mais que les choses soient
claires le bac aujourd'hui l'épreuve de
philosophie va se passer parce que le
rectorat par le biais des chefs
d'établissement a convoqué le ban et
l'arrière-ban pour pouvoir surveiller
les élèves même au mépris de la
réglementation parce que normalement
dans une salle de classe une salle qui
est surveillé pour le baccalauréat il y
a deux personnes qui doivent surveiller
dont obligatoirement en prof le rectorat
a demandé un certain nombre d'années dé
mais aussi de personnels administratifs
dont sony ce ne sont pas les missions
que de surveiller les élèves au bac de
venir surveiller ce matin puisqu'il y à
des perturbations
eu égard au fait que la réforme des
lycées est une réforme catastrophique la
réforme du bac aussi que prévoit le
ministre de l'éducation nationale et
aussi au fond du puits tout ça est dû au
fait que ça fait plusieurs semaines
plusieurs mois même que l'on parle de
ses réformes et cas le ministre ne nous
entend pas on va on va revenir au fond
finalement des raisons de cette colère
aujourd'hui de la part du snes mais vous
dites donc sur le terrain
les examens devraient pas être si
perturbé que cela puisque le ministère
via les différents acteurs parce que
c'est un appel à la grève nationale oui
c'est nationale qui est déclinée aussi
en martinique donc à trouver des
solutions de rechange et aurait en
quelque sorte réquisitionné d'autres
personnels de l'éducation nationale
alors il ne s'agit pas de réquisition
parce que c'est quand même un terme
juridique fort donc ne s'agit pas de
réquisition ils ont fait pression sur
des personnels qui sont venus vers nous
aussi parce que on va les obliger à
surveiller les épreuves il s'agit en
aucun cas de réquisition et je rappelle
que le droit de grève est
constitutionnel et que ces personnels là
aussi à savoir les personnels de vie
scolaire et les administratifs ont le
droit de grève il ne s'agit pas de
réquisition mais ils ont tous fait parce
que juste
man le ministre est extrêmement
difficulté il était le premier de la
classe au sein de son gouvernement
aujourd'hui c'est terminé
il est en difficulté il s'agite et sa
communication extrêmement méprisant
vis-à-vis de l'ensemble du corps
enseignant nous fait dire que ce
monsieur n'aime pas des enseignants et
on ne peut pas diriger un ministère
comme celui de l'éducation nationale qui
l'un des plus importants de du
gouvernement sans aimer ces enseignants
sans et aujourd'hui on se rend compte de
ce mépris là alors les raisons donc
d'une colère qui s'exprime de cette
façon là aujourd'hui au premier jour de
des examens du baccalauréat mais vous
dites que vos revendications
vous les exprimer auprès du ministre au
ministère depuis déjà plusieurs mois
voire même depuis un an plus d'un an
concernant la réforme de l'enseignement
secondaire
oui il s'agit de ça il s'agit de la
réforme de bacs de la réforme aussi des
lycées qui met en concurrence les
disciplines qui met en concurrence les
établissements c'est à celui qui aura le
plus de spécialité c'est à la discipline
dans laquelle il y aura le plus d'élèves
dans les spécialités
enfin il ya tout un ensemble de
concurrence et puis une forme
aujourd'hui de bach maison et nous on
s'interroge quant à nos élèves de
martinique
que sera-t-il de nos élèves de
martinique quand il sera en concurrence
avec parcours sup avec les autres élèves
des grands établissements
vous imaginez bien qu'il faut prendre un
vent d établissement des élèves issus
des établissements les plus favorisés
avant de prendre nos élèves martinique
c'est aussi toute une chaîne qui est
mise en cause tout un ensemble de
réformes qui mettent à mal
l'éducation dans au lycée et qui met à
mal bien évidemment le bac le futur bac
pour l'année prochaine
alors vous pointez l'entière
responsabilité finalement de la
situation sur le ministre jean michel
blanquer remet enfin il a des relais
dans les territoires ici vous par
exemple martinique le snes vous n'avez
pas pris la tâche du recteur son
représentant local en quelque sorte pour
voilà comment c'est entamer des
négociations à propos de cette réforme
essayer de voir ce que vous pouvez faire
modifier le recteur on avait plusieurs
fois mais il faut savoir aussi que le
recteur et pieds et mains liés
ce n'est pas lui qui décide c'est le
ministre qui décide dans toutes les
académies les recteurs ont été vus et
puis nous il nous sommes assez étonnant
que dans toutes les académies
il y ait eu un abandon du système de
réseau qui a été mis en place
il y a seulement l'académie d'aix
marseille et celle de martinique qui
gardent les réseaux qui sont en grande
difficulté et qui met de manière
pratique en grande difficulté les chefs
d'établissement que nous rencontrons au
snes on les voit bien évidemment sur
deux établissements mais aussi lors des
commissions paritaires et qui nous
disent qu'ils ont d'énormes difficultés
avec sept réseaux qui a été mise en
place et décidée par le ministère au
départ et qui a été mis en place par le
recteur
alors que ça a été abandonné par tous
abel de manière pratique ce sera
extrêmement difficile de faire de mettre
en place des emplois du temps convenable
pour les collègues ce qui dégrade et
énormément les conditions de travail et
c'est le ministre qui porte la
responsabilité de cette affaire je rappe
je dis juste le préavis de grève pour la
pour la surveillance
ils datent de trois semaines que dit la
loi que quand il ya un préavis de grève
les le ministre doit rencontrer les
organisations syndicales pour pouvoir
échanger et avec le mépris de ce
ministre mais il n'a strictement pas
convoquer de réunion pour pouvoir
échanger avec des organisations
syndicales
donc il a préféré laisser pourrir la
faire et nous savons très bien
qu'aujourd'hui il va pérorer dans les
médias en disant que tout s'est bien
passé non tout ne s'est pas bien passé
parce qu'il y a aussi déjà beaucoup de
retours 1 du national à cette heure avec
le décalage horaire il ya beaucoup
d'établissements dans lesquels il y à
plus de 50% de grévistes
mais vous imaginez vous savez aussi que
les chiffres en général sont un petit
peu bidouillé par les recteurs il va il
va nous sortir des chiffres qui ne sont
pas en notre faveur mais nous savons
parce que le snes aussi est un syndicat
de lutte que nous continuerons à lutter
parce qu'il s'agit d'une lutte pour nos
élèves
pas pour nous mais pour nos élèves et
leur avenir au sein des lycées
donc vous vous continuerez au delà
de ces épreuves du baccalauréat
finalement qui vont plus ou moins
pouvoir se dérouler selon les situations
au cas par cas
oui bien sûr que nous allons continuer
de nous attendons surtout les réponses
du ministre aujourd'hui nous attendons
qu'ils qu'il appelle les organisations
pour pouvoir faire le point sur nos
revendications parce qu'il s'agit de ça
aussi une négociation c'est chacun qui
fait un pas vers l'autre
mais il ne s'agit pas de méprise et des
personnels que l'on dirige donc vous
vouliez une symbolique très forte un
finalement en actionnant justement ce
préavis
finalement le 17 alors revenons pour
pour conclure valérie verte à leurs yeux
sur la façon dont ça devrait se passer
sur sur le terrain en quelque sorte dans
les salles d'examen comme disent les
jeunes alors les enseignantes et les
enseignants qui ont décidé de faire
grève aujourd'hui de ne pas surveiller
donc ces épreuves du bac
ces premières épreuves comment font-ils
est-ce qu'ils ont obligation de se
déclarer est-ce qu'il faut qu'il se
rende dans la salle d'examen pour
signifier effectivement qui ne veulent
pas surveillée où ils peuvent d'ores et
déjà rester chez eux alors nous sommes
des enseignants du secondaire nous
n'avons strictement aucune obligation de
nous déclarer entend crif east
donc ça veut dire qu'un collègue peut
s'habiller ce matin aller au lycée
écouter une interview et décidé de
rebrousser chemin
tout simplement nous n'avons strictement
aucune obligation donc de nous de les
déclarer en tant que choriste donc les
enseignants qui sont grévistes soit
décide de rejoindre le snes à 8h30 parce
que nous allons échanger aussi avec un
certain nombre d'entre eux soit décide
de rester chez eux parce que ils ont
décidé de lutter contre la grève
la lutte est contre la réforme la chose
et que vous savez pendant toute l'année
on a prévenu les collègues des
difficultés un kick de la réforme et
c'est maintenant qu'ils se rend compte
véritablement qu'il s'agissait pas de
délire de syndicalistes il s'agit
simplement de voir que aujourd'hui ils
se rendent compte que beaucoup de postes
ont été supprimés à cause de cette
réforme qui n'est qu'une réforme
budgétaire et aujourd'hui ils se rendent
compte à quel point la scolarité de nos
élèves pensent que c'est pour eux que
l'on soit bas et je tiens à le répéter
c'est pour eux que l'on soit bah c'est
pas pour
c'est important de le dire parce qu'il
ya certainement des élèves candidats et
des parents d'élèves qui doivent
peut-être être un peu inquiet ce matin
vous savez il ya des parents d'élèves
qui sont aussi des enseignants et qui
aujourd'hui seront en grève
et il y a des parents d'élèves dans les
enfants iront au bac ce matin et qui
seront en grève
donc les choses sont claires pour nous
on se bat pour nos élèves pour leur
avenir est aussi particulièrement pour
nos élèves martiniquais voilà et vous
attendez donc une réponse du ministère
est donc peut-être le rectorat qui
prendra votre attaches dans les
prochains les prochaines heures ou les
prochains jours merci valérie verte
alors yoko secrétaire académique du snes
fsu d'avoir répondu à nos questions
justement autour de cet appel à la grève
de la surveillance des épreuves du
baccalauréat en ce 17 juin
merci bonne journée à vous dit rice et
auditeurs vous retrouver yves bussy